Er. Galt als einer der vielversprechendsten kandidaten für außerirdisches leben der exoplanet proxima centauri
Doch selbst wenn es dort leben gegeben haben sollte am 24 märz 2017 wurde es nach neuesten erkenntnissen
Spätestens vernichtet was ist passiert und was bedeutet das für die alien suche jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich ein herber rückschlag es sieht schlecht aus für leben auf dem exoplaneten proxima centauri bis dato galt
er als ein vielversprechender kandidat für leben in der nähe unseres sonnensystems proxima centauri
Ist ein stern nur 4,2 lichtjahre von uns entfernt und sein
exoplaneten also proxima centauri b kreis in der habitablen zone
Um den stern also da wo wasser nicht verdampft und auch nicht gefriert also
Leben möglich ist zudem ist er fast so groß wie die erde
also, nahezu perfekte bedingungen und wenn nach denen sich immer weiter
verdichteten erkenntnissen gehen das nahezu überall leben entsteht wo die bedingungen dafür da sind dann wäre
außerirdisches leben dort nahezu zwingend gewesen aber
Damit ist es nun aus und vorbei hätte es dort leben gegeben spätestens vor knapp einem jahr
+ 42 lichtjahre wäre es vernichtet worden
Das ergeben jüngste daten analysen ein forschungsteam um die astronomen mary des mcgregor von der carnegie institution
For science hat das sternensystem mit dem atacama large millimeter submillimeter array kurz alma in chile untersucht
Und in den daten jetzt ein
katastrophales ereignis entdeckt merediths mcgregor der 24 märz 2017 war kein normaler tag für proxima centauri
ja an diesem tag passierte eine absolute katastrophe
die temperatur und das muss man sich mal vorstellen stieg für zehn sekunden um achtung das tausendfache an
Maximal war diese eruption auf dem stern sogar zehn mal heißer als die stärksten ausbrüche auf der erde
zitat der flyer erzeugt strahlung, im gesamten bereich des elektromagnetischen spektrums
So das forschungsteam und dabei ist proxima centauri nur ein roter zwerg der exoplaneten b kreis also viel dichter
Um ihn als die erde
Um die sonne um sich in der habitablen
Zone wie hier in unserem system zu befinden dieser flair hat den exoplaneten voll erwischt
Und falls es dort leben gegeben haben sollte ist es spätestens durch diese eruption vernichtet worden aber
Wahrscheinlich war es nicht der erste ausbruch
Meint das forschungsteam zitat in den milliarden jahren seit proxima centauri de entstanden es könnten strahlen ausbrüche wie dieser die
atmosphäre und mögliche ozeane verdampft und die oberfläche des planeten
Sterilisiert haben so merkel mcgregor es ist wirklich zum mäuse melken da findet, man
mal einen vielversprechenden kandidaten für außerirdisches leben und dann gibt es irgendein detail
Das leben doch unmöglich macht bedeutet dass jetzt das es immer so ist also vielleicht doch die these stimmt dass wir
Einzigartig, im universum sind weil es eben doch immer wieder irgendeinen haken gibt wahrscheinlich
Ja wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so es gibt so viele sternsysteme in jeder galaxie
Milliarden und es gibt so viele galaxien auch milliarden statistisch ist es nahezu unmöglich
Dass es kein leben außerhalb der erde gibt wir müssen vielleicht nur etwas länger suchen und die
Erkenntnisse der exo biologen sprechen ja auch dafür das leben relativ schnell entsteht es ist quasi nur eine weiterentwicklung
Aus molekülen und der zwingende weg bei jedem komplexer werdenden system und das passiert
Wohl auch schneller als gedacht ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema
außerirdische und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion folglich zum mitmachen und
Mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier
Passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
außerirdisches leben leben entsteht viel früher als angenommen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran